- [Jesse] It's just inevitable, you know
you gotta roll with, you
gotta go with the flow,
you know?
It's either you're a shark or a guppy.
You know.
And I'll be damned if I'm a guppy!
So, you know, you gotta
do what you gotta do.
So, I grew up in North Hollywood.
It's a mainly a Hispanic community.
Grew up in a gang infested neighborhood.
Just like borderland
projects kind of area.
It's actually, very, back
when I was growing up
it was dangerous, it was
a lot of killing going on
and a lot of drugs,
you know, prostitution.
All on my block.
And the cop station was
actually on the block as well.
It seems like everything
around the cop station
was the worst and then
everything on the outskirts
was safer, but I grew up on the block that
actually had the cop station on it.
And it was crazy around there.
There was prostitutes in
front of the cop station.
It was just, it was crazy.
But um.
You know, I grew up in a, like I said.
Well, I grew up, I was
raised by a single mother.
No father, he was, my mom
just kinda bounced on him.
She just disappeared on
him when I was about three,
because he was on drugs as well.
He was on coke.
From what she said, he
just used to come over,
eat up all the food.
He was just pretty much useless.
And uh.
And so, she just shook him.
She was just like, "Well,
if you're gonna be"
"this kind of father, I can't, it's just"
"better if I disappear on you."
She just shook him and
didn't really think about
how that would have affected.
I don't know, now I think about it
and I'm just like, what about me?
Like, you know, did you
ever even think about
how that would've affected me.
But.
So, yeah, she shook him when I was three.
I never even got to meet him.
I mean, of course, back then,
but I don't remember.
I vaguely remember,
it's like a blur to me,
you know, his face.
I don't even have a picture of him.
I really don't even know
what he looks like, you know.
So, it's a trip.
Throughout my childhood, you know,
there was my moms, you know, companions,
you know, ex-boyfriends or whatever.
There was only one that
actually stood out,
and actually was there while I was,
you know, a teenager or whatever,
but he actually was like
more of the father figure,
really actually was significant.
You know, they didn't work out,
but eventually, but it regardless
that was actually the only dude
that I kind of wanted
to kind of be like him,
because he was a man!
Like you know, he worked hard, you know.
A good example, I guess, someone good
to look up to or whatnot.
But regardless, there was really like
no somebody solid there
throughout my childhood.
So, I had the streets.
My friends, my friends were
just who I would turn to.
I'm an only child.
I mean, I have a sister.
On my mom's side I have a sister.
On my father's side, I don't know her.
On my father's side.
But my sister, I don't
even know her in person.
I just met her over the phone.
And just communicated with her,
because she is actually in El Salvador.
My mom's Salvadorian, my dad is Dominican.
But she was raised over there.
By my grandmother.
My grandmother passed away,
then my aunt raised her.
So.
(coughs)
So, yeah, I'm an only child,
because I was only here.
You know, like, my mom raised me here.
She left my sister over there.
So she raised me here.
And, pretty much an only child.
So I was bored a lot.
There was a lot of boredom
throughout my childhood.
So, I always wanted shit to do.
So I'd just be on the street.
My mom throughout my childhood,
like my mom, she tried to be strict,
but she couldn't handle me.
I was a wild ass kid.
In front of her, I was a good kid.
Soon as she turned her back though,
I was fucking, the horns would come out.
It was just you know, I was
not who she thought I was.
Never, never was who she
thought I was, you know?
But, she was so strict,
she tried to be so strict.
And she tried.
She would always whoop my ass.
You know, that's that old school
Salvadorian, or Hispanic way.
Nowadays, you put your hands on your kid
and you're gonna go to jail.
Or they're gonna take your kids.
Not back in the days.
Back in the days, you
get a good old fashioned
ass whooping!
And that was just it.
You know, grandmas used to just, you know,
wrap up a fucking extension cord
and start whooping our asses.
She would make us kneel on rice.
She would make us kneel on rice
and hold up a chair if we'd fuck up.
You know, we'd be out there terrorizing
and breaking windows and shit like that.
So, let's see.
So anyway, like I said, I grew up in
a gang infested neighborhood.
Eventually, my friends,
that I grew up with,
we were actually very close.
My mom knows all my friends.
We all grew up together.
That was the gang.
That was the gang that grew up there.
The gang that actually
grew up on my block.
That was all my friends,
my closest friends.
So, it wasn't really like a, I mean,
yeah it was a gang thing,
but we were friends.
We were not, it wasn't like, I mean,
I wasn't trying to fit.
It was actually who my friends were.
So, I just fell right into it.
I was raised in it.
I was raised in the
area, it was just part of
you know, where I lived, where I was from.
Or where I'm from.
So.
Let's see.
So, I started using
drugs when I was about,
I must've smoked some weed
when I was about twelve,
for the first time, seventh grade.
Walking home from school.
We started smoking beedies.
I don't know if you know
what beedies are but,
beedies are like these, they were like
leaf wrapped cigarettes.
They used to come in a tiny box, they did.
So that was the first thing ever.
I was like, "What the fuck? Okay."
That was like the first,
my tobacco, right?
And then eventually weed.
You know, we started
walking home from school,
and you know, the weed, the joints started
just getting past around.
In just seventh grade.
I was actually, I was actually
pretty good at school.
As soon as the weed
started coming into play
and all that shit, then I started slacking
on the school work.
I knew all the school work,
but I just didn't do the shit.
I was just lazy.
Shit, I just.
I just wanted to.
Once I got the taste of mind altering,
like I started altering my mind.
That's when I kind of, I was like,
"Oh shit I'll just dope."
Because I kinda wanted
to forget a lot of shit.
Whatever I lacked.
Whatever I felt I lacked,
I just wanted to forget
all that shit.
So, I just wanted to alter my mind.
Forget a lot of shit.
So, weed.
Came in.
And then drinking.
Then, fuck, by the time
I was in eighth grade
I was just, we we're partying it up.
Like, you know, I was after,
we would ditch every Friday.
I don't think there was ever,
I don't think I went
to school on a Friday.
From.
(laughs)
From eighth, from seventh grade,
throughout junior high.
And then I really didn't make it,
well I didn't really make
it, well I did make it
to high school.
Tenth grade, like half of the semester.
And then, you know, I was already going
to juvenile hall and all that shit.
So, I would, you know, get out
go back to school, but
then I started going
to this probation school,
and it was like part of.
And then I went to camp.
It was just like, in and out of jail.
Started probably at 14, was the first time
I went to juvenile hall.
So, yeah, the first time I went,
you know, I didn't get into much trouble,
because I was new to it and you know at 14
I looked like I was about 10,
cause I've always been thin.
First time I hit prison I was 18.
And I looked like I was about 15.
That was quite a fucking experience.
It was some shit.
I got tried as an adult at the age of 17.
Soon as I turned 18 they
shot me to the joint.
I walked in.
I remember like if it was yesterday.
Walking into the prison
yard and I was just like,
"What the fuck."
It was just like a, it was
like a fear, but like uh,
it was like a fear, but at the same time
it was like, "I'm a man
now." type of feeling.
It's fucked up the way.
(laughs)
The way.
The way our, I don't
know, the way our culture
or our society, or our community.
The way that I was brought up.
The way that mind frame.
It just fucking blows my mind,
the way that I was thinking at that time.
I was just like, "Wow! Fuck this!"
But at the same time
it's like "Fuck yeah!"
Because, ever since I was a kid,
growing up with my friends.
We kinda used to talk about that shit.
Like, "Yeah, you know, I'll
probably end up in the joint."
"For sure I gotta go do
at least a couple terms."
Like, "I need at least a
few terms under my belt."
It was like, it was like a fucking goal.
It was like a goal.
It blows my mind how it
was a goal to go to prison.
You know what I mean?
And sure enough, I ended
up in that mother fucker.
For quite some time.
In and out of prison
throughout all my 20's
even up until my 30's.
I'm 40 now.
I'm 40 years old.
I've been out for a few years.
And it's probably the
longest time I've been out.
You know, I've been out five years now.
Five or six years.
- [Interviewer] Kids?
- [Jesse] Yeah, I have two kids.
I have two kids.
I have a 16 year old son.
And uh.
(clicks tongue)
I don't really communicate with him much
because his mom is, uh, is uh,
she's very difficult.
You know.
It seems, it seems like.
It seems like that, you know, her and I
didn't work out for a lot of.
We just didn't work out.
First of all, when we first got together,
it wasn't really a, it
wasn't a love thing.
It was more of a we kinda hooked up.
We were seeing each
other for three months.
I got busted.
To go do a violation.
She comes to the jail,
tells me, "I'm pregnant."
And I was only seeing her.
And I'm like, "Okay."
She's like, "I'm pregnant
and I'm keeping this baby."
And I'm like, "Okay, I guess
we're gonna have to try"
"to work, to try to be together."
I guess, cause you know, we we're
just seeing each other.
(sniffs)
And so, we tried.
But, eh.
Eventually we just figured out
that we weren't that compatible.
And there was some cheating.
You know, just a lot of shit that happened
that just was not, it
just fucked everything up.
Because then there was a
lot of animosity between us.
And that created a distance between.
Back then her only threat was like,
"If you're not with me,
you can't see your son."
So, I kinda just stayed with her.
You know, throughout her cheating.
I put up with it.
Because I just didn't want
to be away from my son.
And eventually that's what
ended up happening anyway.
I caught her cheating.
Red handed.
And then she was so bitter
that I wouldn't take her back
that she distanced my son away from me.
And just would make it
difficult to see him.
And then eventually that made me kind of,
it just discouraged me.
So then I kind of just stopped
trying to communicate as much with him.
So it created a huge distance between us.
Now, it's been.
(exhales)
Wow, it's actually, I haven't seen him
since he was 9, and he's now 16.
Last time I saw him he
was 9, 10, 9, no he was 9.
So, I have a 2 year old daughter as well.
She's just, she's, that's, you know,
that's my world right now.
Because I feel like I have another shot.
At being a father.
It gives me a lot of hope.
And not only that, but
she's crazy about me.
And she's 2 and she's just full of life.
And she's just, you know, happy.
And she's a girl.
So it's like, it's
different having a girl.
When I had a little girl, it changed my,
it changed a lot of shit,
it changed a lot of shit
in my brain.
Because now I have to raise a woman.
And that shit changes everything.
It changes everything.
Because all the shit I did in my life.
Two women, oh god, it's just, fuck.
It's like, oh my god.
I don't want her to ever go
through no shit like that.
So now I just gotta, kinda.
I just have to protect her.
And just stay close to her.
My main goal is to just
become her best friend.
You know, and try to be a good father.
And just to be there, you know.
Be there.
That's just the main thing.
You know, because I
wasn't there for my son.
I just need to make sure that
I'm there for my daughter.
You know.
So as far as family.
My family, my family is a trip.
Man, I have uh, I don't
have a very big family,
but it's all women.
My family's full of women.
I only got one uncle
and like four cousins,
that are, three cousins that are males.
Like three or four cousins that are males.
And the rest is all women.
Just a bunch of women.
And they're all Salvadorian.
Cause I was only raised by the Salvadorian
side of my family.
I wasn't raised by the Dominican side.
You know, my father's Dominican.
I wasn't raised by his family.
I was raised by nothing
but Salvadorians, strong.
And these women, these women are crazy.
They're strong character.
Very bold.
They're fucking straight out.
There's no gray.
It's like, they're crazy
and they don't give a fuck.
And they'll let you know.
And so this is what I was raised by.
By a bunch of women.
And then you know, there was my uncle.
And then a bunch of, a couple of us.
And there's only two of
us that were fuck ups.
Actually three, two of us
as males that were fuck ups.
The rest of the family
is actually not so bad.
Ah, you know.
My family's crazy though because
they don't even get along
between each other and shit.
Like my aunts.
You know they, the aunts and my mom.
And it's just like they all
go at it and it's just chaos.
But there's really no drug
use in my fucking family.
There's just really not.
Like I said, I think I just started using
and all that shit just to forget
a lot of shit that I felt inside me.
But it really wasn't like.
This isn't really, not
something that I actually
saw growing up or my family
was like all into drugs.
It wasn't like that.
It wasn't like that with me.
You know, yeah my mom had ex boyfriends.
And actually that's the first time
I ever saw somebody actually do drugs,
in front of me.
I walked in on my mom's.
And actually that was the dude
that was actually the great
father figure type dude.
And I actually walked in on him, man.
And he was fucking doing a line.
And as soon as I walked in he was like,
(spits)
and just like, "Oh shit!"
And then wiped his nose.
And he was doing a big ass line,
and I was like, "Oh shit!"
And I just kinda closed the door.
So then that kinda opened my eyes.
(coughs)
Cause I was about what, 9.
And kinda like opened my mind
to like, "What the fuck?"
"I've seen that somewhere."
I think I might of heard or seen it
on TV or something, or whatever.
And then it kind of just
like opened my mind to it.
And then I started asking about it.
You know, not him or anything like that,
but I started looking into shit.
I guess I was just
looking for something to.
I was looking to alter my mind.
I feel like I was looking to alter my mind
ever since I was a kid, you know.
And uh, yeah.
So I didn't really get into heavy drugs
until I was about 17.
That's when I tried everything, you know,
at 17, 17.
Because before that, I used to sell drugs.
You know, in the hood, you know.
It was frowned upon if you
would be on that heavy shit.
It was cool if you smoked weed.
And so yeah, we used to
smoke weed and sell rock.
You know, sell crack.
To all the hookers and all the,
I mean all the prostitutes.
(chuckles)
All the prostitutes.
And all the, uh.
Uh you know, all the
dope fiends in the hood.
And it was frowned upon if
we would fuck around with it.
So, we wouldn't.
You know, we would just, we would just.
I think back then, I think uh,
I was about what, 13 when
I first started slangin.
And for us it was more of a fucking.
My mom didn't want to.
She couldn't afford what
I, shit that I wanted
to wear, you know.
She couldn't afford the big ass clothes.
She didn't want to buy
me the big ass clothes
that I wanted to wear.
The big baggy clothes.
And she was like, "I ain't
buying you that shit."
"You figure it out."
You know, so I just started slangin.
And then eventually she was like,
"Where the fuck you
getting so much money?"
I just used to blame it on
my little ex girlfriend.
"Oh, she bought it for
me, she bought it for me."
"Where'd she get money?"
"Oh, her dad gives her money."
You know, it's was just a big ole lie.
And then one time she caught
me selling drugs to a hooker.
I mean to a prostitute, sorry.
She caught me selling
drugs to a prostitute.
Started screaming at me
from the second floor.
"Jesse what the fuck are you doing!"
But she thought I was
dealing with the prostitute.
Like, maybe trying to
get something from her.
Or like you know, trying to
buy some sex or something.
But, she didn't really know.
She was just like, "What
the fuck are you doing?"
And I was just like,
"Uh, nothing nothing."
And I just through her off.
I was like, "What, she just
lives down the street."
"And I know who she is."
She was like, "Don't talk
them, they're hookers."
"Don't fucking talk to them."
And then I was just like,
"Oh, okay, my bad, whatever."
See, she thought I was
like a innocent kid.
She didn't know I was a
full blown mother fucking.
You know.
I had a gun.
I had, it was like, you know.
She didn't know anything about any gun.
Until, you know, they raided my pad
when I was, you know, a kid.
And then she broke out
a shotgun and a gun.
And she was like, "What the fuck!"
And then they told my mom, you know,
"Did you know your son's a gang member?"
She was like, "What!"
And she just was oblivious.
She did not know shit.
Because I hid it.
Good from her, you know
what I'm saying, like.
It was obvious, but my mom was real naive
to shit like that.
She's so old fashioned.
She's from the, you know, the country.
This is very close minded type shit.
But yeah, I mean, you know.
She just didn't want to.
In a sense, I just don't think she wanted
to believe I was an active gang member.
She didn't want to believe that shit.
She thought my friends
were just, you know,
"Those are his friends."
You know, they all just, you know.
Even though I would tell her all the time,
"Oh yeah, you know so and so,
he got busted, he's in jail."
"Oh, for what?"
And then, it was just like a thing.
You know, but we're in the hood.
So these things were
like, they like happen.
She just never, it never
dawned on her that,
"Are you mother fuckers
like gang members?"
Like, she never, you know.
"Oh yeah, what's his name got shot."
And she, "Oh yeah, who shot him?"
"Like why?"
Like you know, oh she.
It's like my mom was really
naive to a lot of shit.
Because she's straight from the country.
She's not, you know, she
wasn't raised here or nothing.
Uh.
(sighs)
But now she's up on everything.
She knows what's up now.
You know, because fuck.
Because after all the
shit I put her through
and went through.
Um, yeah.
So at about 16, 17 I started
fucking around with primos.
You know, mix the crack with the weed.
Because I used to sell crack.
So we used to, we started rolling primos.
Tried that and that shit was like, "Whoa."
And then I just kinda went
on one with that shit.
I really went in with
that and did it hard.
Because that's actually how I ended up
catching that first case.
You know, we started doing robberies
and all kinds of shit.
And then we really went in
on the whole gang banging.
Like, we really went balls out.
It seems like it just fucking,
turned a switch.
Just turned into everything
was like, "Fuck it."
And I don't, you know, and everything
turned into, "Fuck it."
And, "I don't give a fuck."
And my attitude changed.
I don't know, a lot of shit changed.
Didn't really give a fuck.
And then I just turned into
this mean mother fucking.
I don't know.
I feel like all the shit
that I wanted to forget.
You know, like I said
before, there's a lot of shit
that I just wanted to forget, so.
So uh.
I was very angry.
I was very angry growing up.
Like as a kid.
As a kid, I was like a sad kind of kid.
But as soon as I turned into a teenager
that sadness turned into like anger.
And then I was just violent.
I became violent.
I was very violent kid.
I was fighting all the
fucking time, you know.
I might of got my ass whooped so.
I got my ass whooped so many times.
Because I would pick
fights and get my ass beat.
You know.
But eventually, you know,
after so many ass beatings
you eventually kind of learn how to fight.
And then you think you're cool.
And then you just start picking fights.
And then you just start
fighting everybody.
And then you know, uh yeah.
Growing up was violence for me.
A lot of violence.
Lot of violence.
Lot of guns and drugs.
Meanwhile, my mom's
naive to a lot of shit.
Didn't really know what was cracking.
So, let's see.
Started uh.
I went to prison.
I went to prison in.
I went to prison in, ah fuck.
I've been to prison like five times, man.
I've been to prison five times.
Did a few terms.
4 years, 3 years, 2
years, 2 years, 2 years.
A lot of guns.
I have four gun charges.
I mean, they come with other shit.
But I have a lot of guns in my rap sheet.
I felt like I always needed one, you know.
I felt like.
A lot of homies that got smoked,
you know that got killed.
And I felt like, "Fuck that".
I'd rather get caught
with one than without one.
You know what I'm saying.
So, I always kept them.
I always kept a gun, man.
I always kept a burner.
Always.
Uh.
Um.
Just kept getting caught with
the mother fuckers though.
I went on a high speed pursuit.
I went on two high speed pursuits.
I was on the news once.
(chuckles)
I got like 15 seconds on the air.
I went on a high speed pursuit
here in Skid Row.
All through this mother fucker.
Just high, full speed.
Until finally I got caught in traffic
and jumped out the car and started running
through the Flower District.
Threw the gun in a big
ass bucket of water.
Finally, they caught me.
And they still found the clip.
So I still got a year for
possession of ammunition.
Cause I had gun charges before that.
So I ended up back in prison for
a year and a half or so.
(sighs)
First time I went to prison, man,
I was only supposed to do, you know,
I got tried as an adult.
I was only supposed to
do 16 months with half.
I turned that 16 months with half time.
Which was only supposed to be 9 months
it turned out to be back then.
At 9 months I turned
into 4 years 3 months.
Because I started fucking up.
You know, there's a lot
of shit that you gotta do
when you're in there.
It's inevitable.
You know, it's like, you know.
They, some shit's just
inevitable, you know.
You gotta roll with, you
gotta go with the flow.
You know.
It's either you're a shark or a guppy.
And I'll be damned if I'm a guppy!
So you know.
You gotta do what you gotta do.
Especially at that age.
You know, at that age,
it's like you gotta kinda
prove yourself.
You know, you're brand new.
You know, you gotta go hard.
So, I did.
I just ended up stuck there
for quite a while, so.
You know, I got out and
just went women crazy.
I got out at 20, I was out at,
22 I think I got out.
22 March 4, 2002.
I'll never forget that day I flew home.
Flew home from Sacramento, you know.
They drove me four hours
north, I mean south
to Sacramento, flew home from Sac.
Arrived in Burbank, jumped out the plane.
Fucking gone in a minute.
Didn't even know how to get home.
Finally it dawned onto me like,
"Fuck it, I'll just catch a cab."
Went home.
My mom wasn't home.
Nobody's home.
It's like uh.
I went to go knock at the manager's door.
It's whole nother manager.
And then I don't know, it just,
it was a trip.
You know, time.
Time, man, is it's a most precious thing.
It's some shit you can never get back.
That's why they take
it from you, you know.
You lose out on a lot of shit.
You miss out on life.
You know, people die
while you're in there.
People have kids.
I got out and fucking everybody had kids.
What the fuck?
It's like everybody had kids.
When I got out everybody had kids.
And it was a trip man.
People got married.
People had kids.
Some people died.
Other people just had
some crazy experiences.
It's just like you miss
out on a lot of shit.
Like, you know, my aunt
passed away while I was.
You know, my favorite
aunt, you know, passed away
while I was in there.
That shit fucked me up, because.
And then on another term
another one of my aunts
passed away, you know.
And it was like, it was fucked up.
Man, you miss out on
some shit that you know,
you just, you know.
Important.
Significant things that you know.
- [Interviewer] Who are you today?
- What's that?
- [Interviewer] Today,
where are you at today?
- So today.
(sighs)
I'm still fucking up.
But throughout the years, man I still,
I don't know.
One thing, I've always been blessed
to be able to bounce back.
Immediately.
Like I get out of prison
and then I bounce back.
Right away I'm on my feet.
You know, I get a job and I'm on point
and then boom.
So, I actually managed
to put myself through,
trade school.
It wasn't a trade school.
It was a.
I became a union plumber.
And so through the union
they send you to school.
So I made it up to what, I think
the second year apprenticeship.
But I got all the schooling and then
I still kept all the books.
So then I just kinda rolled with
the whole plumbing thing.
And now I'm, you know, a skilled plumber.
I know how to re-pipe a whole
house from the ground up.
So, I've been doing it now for what?
Since I've been out.
So, 6 years I've been doing plumbing.
And I'm pretty fucking good at it.
So, that's what I do.
Now I'm a plumber.
And I just seem to just.
It's like uh, it's like uh.
I self destruct.
Man, cause I know that I can get
whatever the fuck I want quickly.
So, it's like I, bah, I
don't give a shit sometimes.
And I'll fuck off a few thousand dollars
just because I know I
can get it right back.
(snaps)
Uh, it's a fucked up thing because,
it's like self sabotage, you know.
It's, shit's not cool, man.
It's like chip on my shoulder type shit.
It's like a confidence that
I know I can get the shit.
You know, it's nothing.
And so I fuck it off.
It's insane.
It's fucking weird.
I don't even know, you know.
I've been to rehab a few times.
And that's where I learned a lot of shit
about myself that I didn't know.
Why I think the way I think.
Kind of got to define a
lot of things about myself.
And you know, you got through therapy.
You do all kinds of stuff in there
that teaches you about yourself.
You do a lot of writing too.
So, writing about yourself
teaches you about yourself.
You know, as you write, you kind of
you go back to read it
and you're just like
"Holy shit!"
You know, it's like you're
learning about yourself.
And I never really tripped on that
until I went to rehab, you know.
I've been to rehab
fucking four times, man.
And I'm about to go back.
You know what I'm saying.
- [Interviewer] And crack is your drug?
- Uh, yeah, it's uh, I mean, you know.
I drink.
I smoke.
Primos and coco puffs
and cocaine and a little
bit of carga, you know.
Heroine that is.
Every now and then.
I'm not like, no, I don't
slam or none of that.
I snort it.
But I've done it all though.
I've smoked PCP.
I've, fucking acid, shrooms, uh.
You know, coke, speed,
meth, fucking heroine.
You know.
I mean, there's probably
only a couple drugs.
I don't think I've ever tried ecstasy.
I heard that's the shit.
(chuckles)
But I mean, you know, there's probably
only a few drugs that I haven't done.
But for the most part, I don't want
no new habits.
I really, you know.
I've had my share of shit already with
the ones I have done.
So now I'm like.
There's really no solid place, you know,
that I could actually say that
I'm actually living there.
Because, yeah, my mom's place is always
a place that I can go to.
But I don't like to be there.
I'm 40 years old.
So, I don't want.
My mom has a roommate.
And that means that I have
to sleep in the living room.
And I don't, I feel like
too fucking old for that.
So I'd just rather not be there.
And I'd rather not be there.
So I'll rent rooms and
fucking be jumping around
from motel to motel.
Airbnb, whatever.
I just bounce around from
motel to motel, you know.
And I hustle, and I
work, so I'm, you know.
And then I'll come fuck off a week
over here in Skid Row,
you know what I'm saying.
Or in a whole nother area
that's like Skid Row.
You know what I'm saying.
It's just a, you know.
And I've been coming
around this mother fucker
for quite some time, I've been.
I first came to Skid Row when I was about,
20, well yeah, I was about 22.
First time I ever.
First time I ever actually came here
to score dope, I came
with a bunch of friends.
And we were 17, all right.
That was in '97.
Shit was way different
back then, over here man.
Shit was way different.
This was crazier.
And then I didn't come back until,
you know, I got out of prison.
So I came back when I was 22.
Then I still kinda came
back every now and then.
But see, I would just
come score and bounce.
I would just leave.
But see, now recently,
these past six years
I've kinda been over here a lot.
Not a lot like to where I live here,
but I'm here a lot.
You know.
I come over here.
And I rent rooms around
this mother fucker.
And just, you know, and post up and slang
to support my own fucking habit.
Or not even slang, I
hustle and it's just like,
there's so much shit
that I can't even mention
that I have to do.
Like, I'm not saying, like,
I don't do no weird shit.
But I do a lot of illegal shit, you know.
And, you know, and that's
how we support our habit
around this mother fucker, you know.
And we hit licks.
We do all kinds of shit.
We, you know.
It's just how it is.
Man, when you're out there trying
to chase that shit, you know.
You pretty much do whatever the fuck needs
to get done, you know, to
get that shit, you know.
It's fucked up, but it is what it is.
That's just how it is, you know.
- [Interviewer] I'm gonna close it out.
You did great.
You did a great job.
You can close it out.
I think we're golden.
- I mean hey.
I just, I know that I'm not,
you know, this ain't how I'm gonna live
the rest of my life.
I'm 40 years old.
I'm probably only gonna
live another 20 years,
considering, I have had bad eating habits
since I was a kid.
All the drugs and shit.
I probably don't have a life expectancy
past 65 or some shit.
But I know that this ain't it for me, man.
This is, this is.
This is fucked up, you know.
And I hope, that, you know.
I hope I can open some eyes, man.
You know.
And maybe hopefully, you
know, plant some seeds
in some brains out there in the world
to where people know that this ain't,
this is not how you wanna live.
You know, kids.
Times are different now, you know.
I think that it's very
important to know how
to deal with your stresses.
Whatever life brings your way,
I feel like you have to figure out
how you deal with the stress.
Whether it's exercise,
whether it's sports,
whether it's, you gotta
keep yourself busy.
Because boredom, it's
like my mom would say,
"Boredom is like, idle time
is the devil's playground."
So if you ain't got shit to
do, find some shit to do.
Get into something.
Figure out what your passion is.
Do what the fuck that is.
Because if you're bored a lot, that means
you're not trying to
figure out what you love.
You know, figure out what you love to do.
Whatever you're passionate about.
And do that.
And figure out a way to
get paid for that shit.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
Thank you Jesse.
Thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] Great job.
You did it.